Shure: 为什么写着原浆啤酒三元一罐，可打开冰箱却一罐啤酒没有
Shure: 为什么为什么
Shure: 保卫黄河保卫华北保卫全中国
Jake:我靠 你把这三台电脑烧了
其他人：这一连串的
Shure: 是不是要吃什么东西，我把麻将卸了吧
Jake:行啊可以
Jake:哎，没灯了没灯没灯了
Jake:是啊
Katrina: 会不会在楼上
Shure: 应该不会吧
Shure: 给家人们表演一个卸麻酱
Jake:好嘞
Jake:充电宝是吧
Lucia: 好像没找到
Jake:这个可以先试试
Lucia: 哦你已经充满了
Jake:我有很多电脑，我可以插在电脑上
其他人：你那个还没好吗我这个一共才16分钟
Jake:你们是一台电一种电脑，哦有点奇怪
其他人：这个导完一次可有重插吗
Jake:但是你要知道这是一个脆弱的硬盘，你要规范使用它。它很脆弱
其他人：要先弹出是吗
Jake:你要规范使用它。它很脆弱
Jake:它很便宜它很脆弱
Jake:那个 那个充电宝给我
其他人：咱们要买USB3.0所以慢
Jake:那几点零快
其他人：还有更新的吗
其他人：那是不现在都不用USB了
Jake:你什么专业来着哈哈哈
其他人：那也不学这个啊不会教我们USB
Jake:麻将专业
其他人：那个咖啡液还有吗
Jake:有有的
Jake:开了吗
Lucia: 开了吗现在
Lucia: 开了吗  快了快了
Jake:电连了没有开
Jake:是没电了，所以
Lucia: 没电了然后他就
Jake:okok那你你等它
其他人：来首普通朋友
Jake:它应该  你现在充电到百分之十就可以录了
Lucia: 3：37哦对那就是前面断了
Jake:对对对
Lucia: 它在1小时21分钟断了
Jake:你电很少不能录可能充到10%才能录
其他人：这有纸吗拿一张纸
Jake:想陶喆啦 忍不住啦
其他人：别踩地上的咖啡
Jake:这个水桶怎么用
Lucia: 就是你说的是那个按一下它就开始出水
Lucia: 再按它就停下
Jake:按那个
Lucia: 按那个红点
Lucia: 如果它和楼上是一样的
Jake:它要等吗
Lucia: 不需要等
Lucia: 你再按一下
Lucia: 楼上那个不需要等 这是没插电吗
Jake:要插电是吧
Jake: 那我上楼去接水吧
Lucia: 没插电这有电吗
Jake:不用了，我上楼接去
Lucia: 那要不然你上楼吧
Jake:好好好我上楼接去
Jake:一会他们收拾完房间，然后你们也收拾一下房间
Jake:收拾完之后，带我们讲一下要干什么
Jake:行吗你们
Lucia: 现在准备出方案了是吧
Tasha: 出什么方案
Jake:没有处罚，只是加一些环节。
Jake:然后吃火锅，吃完火锅之后把礼物送掉
其他人：好
Jake:你好什么
Jake:我们还是到二楼吃火锅，我们上去把桌子给搬中间去
Jake:一楼确实乱了点，一点都吃不了
Jake:还没弄好，还没传好
其他人：快了67%
Jake:卧槽
其他人：他这个传14G和我这个传47G时间差不多
其他人：卧槽你这个速度比我这个慢了30倍
其他人：卧槽忘了打麻将了
Jake:硕帮我们拍一张
Shure: 拍什么
Jake:照
Jake:对，联机开黑
Jake:we three
Jake:摆拍摆拍，不要打麻将了
Jake:发给老板看了
Katrina: cheers
其他人：cheers
Jake:来我就这样作为一个老板
Jake:你干活呀，你这是干嘛呀哈哈哈
Shure: 你得一边喝着咖啡一边
Shure: 谢斌竹脸没露出来对对对好好好，
Shure: 对对对好好好，然后你在那个帅往右边侧一侧脸
Jake:这边这边
Shure: 再往后一点再往后一点
Shure: 然后再往右一点帅
Shure: 脸往右侧一点
Jake:就上新闻联播不也不过这样
Shure: 无敌这张
Jake:无敌
Jake:这这个没没拍全啊，少拍了几台电脑
Shure: 怎么摸鱼呢
Jake:这个一般是什么创业镜头是吧，等到市值百亿的时候这张照片
Jake:我怎么jump
其他人：可以手机直接对着
其他人：直接对着我的手机
Jake:哦哦哦，我得这么jump
Jake:是这个吗
其他人：着我的直接给我吧
Jake:你的可能，你们俩在互相传
其他人：就一张
其他人：再来一张
其他人：这一张刘帅显得
其他人：这一张刘帅是二老板
Jake:哦哦哦来来来，打扫了
其他人：原来刘帅是二老板
Shure: 哎很伤心
Shure: 还没满day
Jake:哎次日
Jake:去吧 可以
其他人：简单打扫
Jake:帮忙整理整理
Lucia: 就厕所那些垃圾
Jake:对，门口有好多垃圾 就门后面
Jake:门后面垃圾是归谁清理的
其他人：哪个门后，这些都不要了吗
Jake:我们纸盒还有机会用上吗 ，还是挑一挑
Lucia: 纸盒有几个我挑了确定不要的
Jake:OK OK
Lucia: 这个也可以不要了
Jake:那要的我们放出来吧
Lucia: 这几个可以先留一下
Lucia: 因为它挺结实的看我们后面有没有空做
Lucia: 这个其实可留可不留但是里面好像还有东西
Jake:好
Lucia: 这个比较大如果需要盛长的东西
Jake:等一下，我接个电话
Lucia: 啊没事没事
Jake:哎哎哈喽哈喽，你好你好你好啊。你在哪啊
快递员：这个铁门这啊
Jake:呃呃 哪个铁门啊
Jake:我看一下啊
Jake:我是皇家新村
Jake:你在  你在哪 你进不去的地方
Jake:您是什么快递啊
Jake:京东  好嘞好嘞
Jake:我也能拍到其实
其他人：拔了重插一下
其他人：卧槽才
Jake:对啊 有点牛逼啊
其他人：这张可以这张发给紫伟
Jake:知道这么为什么能拍出这种照片是吗
Jake:这个很难reason
Jake:我拍了一个这个
Katrina: 哦真的
Jake:有点厉害
Shure: 可以
Katrina: 啥时去看小狗啊
Jake:现在可以去了
Jake:你插上电我们对齐就可以去
Shure: 我卸好麻酱了
Shure: 但这个麻酱是淡的
Shure: 咱们没有酱油
Jake:试试开机
Lucia: 哦对没开我以为已经开了
Jake:看看你的电，帅
Shure: 我的一直在连着，所以他一定是100%。
Lucia: 我的应该可以了现在已经13%了
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 没有多余的
Shure: There's no extra ones.
Lucia: 可以了
Lucia: It's okay.
Shure: 皮套之类的东西吗
Shure: Things like hair ties?
Lucia: 多余的什么
Lucia: Extra what?
Shure: 皮套之类的
Shure: Like hair ties.
Lucia: 什么叫皮套
Lucia: What's a hair tie?
Shure: 就是扎头发那种
Shure: It's like a rubber band for hair.
Lucia: 啊皮筋啊
Lucia: Ah, a rubber band.
Shure: 对皮筋
Shure: Yes, a rubber band.
Jake:呀你这鞋还是同款的呀
Jake: Hey, your shoes are the same model!
Jake:怎么做到的
Jake: How did you manage that?
Shure: 呃也不是
Shure: Uh, not really.
Shure: 就是买了点彩虹元素
Shure: I just bought some with rainbow elements.
Shure: 但是本人并不是的
Shure: But I'm not actually into that.
Jake:oh
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 我要把头发扎起来太长了
Shure: I need to tie my hair up, it's too long.
Tasha: 不会谢掉吧
Tasha: It won't fall off, right?
Alice: 永不凋谢的花
Alice: A flower that never withers.
Jake:嚯这糖怎么办
Jake: What should we do with this candy?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Jake:给它融了倒掉是吧
Jake: Just melt it and pour it out, right?
Lucia: 倒了
Lucia: Poured it out.
Jake:糖有点厉害
其他人：这都扔了吗
Jake:呃我看一下
Jake: Uh, let me see.
Jake:问一下
Jake: Let me ask.
Jake:薇薇
Jake:扔吗
Tasha: 什么
Lucia: 嗯扔什么
Lucia: Hmm, throw what away?
Lucia: 嗷
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:这小包要不要扔
Jake:收拾好了
Jake: All cleaned up.
Katrina: 走不走看狗去
Katrina: Shall we go see the dog?
Katrina: 然后要回来搞搞饭了
Katrina: Then we need to come back and make dinner.
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:对去看狗吧
Jake: Yeah, let's go see the dog.
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 他还在吗
Katrina: Is he still there?
Katrina: 他俩去吗
Katrina: Are they going?
Choiszt: 应该在你们俩去看
Choiszt: They should be there. You two go check.
Katrina: 你们俩去吗
Katrina: Are you two going?
Katrina: 你俩去吗
Jake:你俩开导了吗
Jake: Have you two talked them into it?
Alice:卫生间收了吗
Alice: Has the bathroom been cleaned?
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 楼上那个洗手间也换一下可以吗
Lucia: Can you also change the trash bag in the upstairs bathroom?
Lucia: 就是垃圾袋
Lucia: Just the trash bag.
Lucia: 哦好谢谢啊
Lucia: Oh, thanks a lot.
其他人：垃圾能收的都收了你上去看一眼还有哪没拿的没事
Lucia: 哦也行
Lucia: Oh, that works too.
其他人：去吧
其他人：先洗洗
Shure: 这箱子我们留着还有点用
Shure: Let's keep this box, it might still be useful.
其他人：来我再给你们留两个纸
Jake:谢谢您
Jake:搁哪呢
Jake:搁这吧
Lucia: 啊可以的
Lucia: Ah, it's fine.
Lucia: 只要就是主要就是那个垃圾桶
Lucia: The main thing is just the trash can.
Lucia: 收拾一下就行了
Lucia: Just clean it up a bit.
Choiszt: 我把其他插进去
Choiszt: I'll plug in the other stuff.
Lucia: 呃这边的这些箱纸箱吗
Lucia: Uh, these cardboard boxes here?
Lucia: 这这这这个都可以不要了然后
Lucia: These, these, these, we don't need them anymore and...
Lucia: 呃这个这个也不要了
Lucia: Uh, we don't need this one either.
Jake:研究完了
Jake: Finished studying it?
Jake:研究出了idea
Jake: Got an idea from it?
Lucia: 对这都是不用了
Lucia: Yes, we don't need any of these.
Jake:idea出来了
Jake: Idea came out?
Alice:呃一个比较杂乱的idea
Alice: Uh, it's a rather messy idea.
Lucia: 对对然后这也是
Lucia: Yeah, and this one too.
Jake:OK行
Jake: OK, got it.
Lucia: 嗯对那个应该是外卖垃圾
Lucia: Mm, yeah, that should be the takeout trash.
Jake:那一块可以聊聊
Jake: We can discuss that part.
Lucia: 对对对然后这个这个箱子也不要了
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, and this box, we don't need it either.
Katrina: 你知道就是嗯那种
Katrina: You know, like, um...
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Katrina: 就是小玩偶然后他可以抱在那个
Katrina: Like those little toys, and you can hang them on...
Katrina: 就是这种门把手上那个叫什么挂件吗
Katrina: Like on door handles, what are those called, keychains?
Lucia: 其他有几个我们好像还没
Lucia: There are a few we haven't...
Lucia: 没看这京东快递
Lucia: Checked this JD package yet.
Alice:门把手挂机
Alice: Door handle hangers.
Lucia: 这刚拿回来的吗
Lucia: Did this just arrive?
Lucia: 先放这吧
Lucia: Let's put it here first.
Lucia: 呃这个别的这个好像还没拆
Lucia: Uh, this one, we haven't unwrapped it yet.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:那什么啪啪圈什么
Alice: What, slap bracelet or something?
Jake:谢斌竹这样会快吗
Alice:你可以试着搜类似的然后看有没有
Alice: You can try searching for similar ones and see if there are any.
Alice:啪啪圈试着搜一下
Alice: Try searching for “PaPaQuan.”
其他人：你这都改充电了
Jake:呃对齐一下
Jake: Uh, align it.
Jake:对齐之后就可以
Jake: Once it's aligned, it's good.
Katrina: 就就还有那种可以
Katrina: And there's also the kind that...
Katrina: 就是你背书包上
Katrina: ...you can attach to your backpack.
Katrina: 他有抱在你书包上的那种
Katrina: It can be hugged on your backpack.
Shure: 然后说这
Shure: And then say this...
Katrina: 叫什么挂件
Katrina: What's it called, a pendant?
Shure: 这是我们小时候玩的最早的SM哈哈哈
Shure: This is the earliest form of SM we played as kids, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈够了真的是
Katrina: Haha, enough already!
Katrina: 走吧你们去不去散散步
Katrina: Let's go, are you going for a walk?
Jake:来对齐对齐
Jake: Come on, align it, align it.
Lucia: 哎咱门口就是
Lucia: Hey, at the entrance...
Jake:看看时间先看这个
Jake: Check the time, look at this first.
Lucia: 那那些箱子是已经收拾过的吗
Lucia: Have those boxes already been packed?
Jake:然后
Jake: And then...
Lucia: 门口最最最最头这些这些我不太确定
Lucia: At the very front, I'm not too sure about these.
Alice:讲好了吗
Alice: Have you finished talking?
Shure: 浇好了
Shure: Yeah, done.
Jake:这些其实都不用都不用
Jake: We really don't need these, don't need them.
Shure: 有点稀了
Shure: It's a bit thin.
Lucia: 啊那也行
Lucia: Ah, that's fine.
Shure: 本来是水多了
Shure: It was too watery.
Lucia: 这个这个也是个外卖袋子是吗
Lucia: This, this is a takeout bag, right?
Lucia: 外卖袋子就扔了吧对这个
Lucia: Just throw away the takeout bags, right, this one.
Jake:对啊外卖袋子可以丢·
Jake: Yeah, takeout bags can be thrown away.
其他人：因为有些东西我没敢给你们动不知道那些有用那些没用
Lucia: 哎行行谢谢
Lucia: Alright, thanks.
Lucia: 这些盒
Lucia: These boxes...
Lucia: 这些盒好像都还挺结实可以放一下
Lucia: These boxes seem pretty sturdy, we can keep them.
Lucia: 啊谢谢您啊
Lucia: Ah, thank you.
Jake:亮灯了哎
Jake: The light's on, hey.
Jake:亮了亮了
Jake: It's on, it's on.
Lucia: 晾了吧好的
Lucia: Let it dry, okay.
Jake:很对累的不得了
Jake: I'm so tired, can't take it anymore.
Shure: 你们怎么私闯我的房间呢
Shure: How did you guys break into my room?
Katrina: go 不 go
Jake:看钟
Lucia: 哎又校准一次
Lucia: Oh, calibrate it again.
Shure: 你要你要
Shure: You, you.
Jake:你没电了
Jake: You ran out of battery.
Tasha: 没有电了
Jake:你不亮了
Jake:那是怎么回事
Jake: What's going on?
Katrina: 走不走走不走
Katrina: Are we going or not?
Jake:看看你的电
Jake: Check your battery.
Katrina: 要走赶紧走
Katrina: If we're going, let's go quickly.
Jake:还是他会这有电
Jake: Or maybe it has power.
Jake:插上的
Jake: Plugged in.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 很艺术你看那画家的感觉走不走
Katrina: It's artistic, look at that painter's vibe. Are we going?
Jake:哎没充其实
Jake:按一下才能充
Jake: You have to press it to charge.
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:所以
Jake: So.
Katrina: 溜一圈回来
Katrina: Let's take a quick walk.
Katrina: 今天还没出去透气
Katrina: We haven't had fresh air today.
Jake:所以你要开一下
Jake: So you have to start it.
其他人：你帮我看着点
Lucia: 虽然很难想
Lucia: Although it's hard to imagine.
Lucia: 不过我觉得我有一个大概的计划了
Lucia: But I think I have a rough plan.
Alice:你选了几呀
Alice: How many did you pick?
Lucia: 我就是我计划里的
Lucia: It's just part of my plan.
Lucia: 现在有一二三四五个
Lucia: Now there are one, two, three, four, five.
Jake:你要等一
Jake: You have to wait.
其他人：这个有点抽象
Jake:为什么
Lucia: 五个东西就是可以用来装饰一下的
Lucia: Five things that can be used for decoration.
Jake:这什么啊
Lucia: 不过还没下单
Lucia: But we haven't ordered yet.
Jake:血管是吧
Lucia: 因为我还没想好然后可能
Lucia: Because I haven't decided yet, and maybe...
其他人：走吧
其他人：走
Lucia: 可能再加一点贴纸或者之类的东西
Lucia: Maybe I'll add some stickers or something like that.
Alice:我
Alice: I...
Jake:没关系你一会再拍吧
Jake: It's okay, you can take the photo later.
Lucia: 如果我们有预算
Lucia: If we have the budget...
Lucia: 我是不是可以买个娃娃
Lucia: Can I buy a doll...
Lucia: 把它当成装饰
Lucia: And use it as a decoration...
Lucia: 最后再带回去
Lucia: And take it back later.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Lucia: 就是符合我的那个风格的
Lucia: As long as it matches my style.
Alice:设计怎么样了
Alice: How's the design going?
Tasha:画
Tasha: Drawing.
Alice:啊我也喜欢地毯
Alice: Ah, I also like carpets.
Lucia: 啊哎
Lucia: Ah, hey.
Lucia: 我没有放地毯
Lucia: I didn't put a carpet.
Lucia: 不过我因为我那个房间进去那个空间
Lucia: Because my room, when you go in, that space...
Lucia: 它是有一个那
Lucia: It has a...
Lucia: 样的然后再进去我觉得不是很好选
Lucia: And then when you go in, I think it's not easy to choose.
Alice:的嗯对
Alice: Hmm, right.
Lucia: 地毯我就没选
Lucia: So I didn't choose a carpet.
Lucia: 哦不过咱俩户型是一样的应该
Lucia: Oh, but our layouts should be the same.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia: 我想搞一个
Lucia: I want to make one...
Alice:那我们现在正在录的话
Alice: If we're recording now...
Alice:应该可以说了吧
Alice: We should be able to say it, right?
Lucia: 对可以说了吧
Lucia: Yeah, we can say it.
Lucia: 咱不是专门把这个留着
Lucia: We were saving this for...
Alice:因为
Alice: Because...
Lucia: 但是微微的还没打开
Lucia: But Tasha hasn't opened it yet.
Lucia: 应该没关系
Lucia: It should be fine.
Lucia: 我想弄一个
Lucia: I want to make one...
Lucia: 就是那种毛毡照片墙
Lucia: Like a felt photo wall.
Lucia: 就可以拿图钉往上戳照片的那个
Lucia: 然后我看他好像买那个照片墙
Lucia: And I saw that when you buy that photo wall...
Lucia: 就会送美文纸
Lucia: They give you some inspirational paper.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我就可以直接贴在墙上
Lucia: I can just stick it on the wall.
Lucia: 对那你想做什么风格
Lucia: Right, so what style do you want?
Lucia: 其实我想做蓝色系
Lucia: Actually, I want to go with a blue theme.
Alice:我昨天想过
Alice: I thought about it yesterday.
Alice:但是
Alice: But...
Alice:我就是没有找到我喜欢的那个蓝色
Alice: I just couldn't find the shade of blue I liked.
Alice:然后我就换了换成
Alice: So I switched to...
Alice:森林的那种感觉
Alice: A forest kind of vibe.
Lucia: 啊我现在
Lucia: Ah, right now...
Alice:嗯绿色的其实我不是很喜欢绿色
Alice: Hmm, green, actually I'm not a big fan of green.
Lucia: 我现在
Lucia: Right now...
Lucia: 我现在想法可能是做一点偏地中海
Lucia: I'm thinking of doing something Mediterranean.
Alice:海洋
Alice: Ocean.
Lucia: 对对对对那种风格
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, that kind of style.
Lucia: 所以我想再买一个
Lucia: So I want to buy another...
Lucia: 再买一张渔网
Lucia: Another fishnet.
Lucia: 然后咱们把它挂一下
Lucia: Then we can hang it up.
Lucia: 我刚就是在想怎样挂会比较好看
Lucia: I was just thinking about how to hang it nicely.
Alice:那个渔网
Alice: That fishnet...
Alice:挂的话你是不是可以买点什么水母啊
Alice: If you hang it, maybe you can buy some jellyfish decorations.
Lucia: 可以买点什么水母啊
Lucia: Buy some jellyfish decorations.
Lucia: 或者贝壳那种元素在上面
Lucia: Or shells, that kind of elements.
Lucia: 对我也是在想这个
Lucia: Yeah, I was thinking the same.
Lucia: 就把它点缀一下
Lucia: Just to decorate it a bit.
Lucia: 但我还在想怎么挂
Lucia: But I'm still thinking about how to hang it.
Lucia: 就要不然把它直接挂在照片墙上
Lucia: Maybe just hang it directly on the photo wall.
Lucia: 然后再然后再在那个渔网上面戳照片
Lucia: Then, we can pin photos on the fishnet.
Alice:我昨天瘦了一圈
Alice: I lost some weight yesterday.
Lucia: 但我好像没
Lucia: But I seem to have...
Lucia: 我觉得现在好像不太来得及打印照片
Lucia: I think it's too late to print photos now.
Lucia: 我要不要买几张图算了
Lucia: Should I just buy a few pictures?
Lucia: 可能也很便宜买几张明信片
Lucia: It might be cheaper to buy a few postcards.
Alice:昨天想了很多的
Alice: I thought a lot yesterday.
Alice:呃星星就水星海母贝壳用海洋元素
Alice: Uh, stars, jellyfish, shells, using ocean elements.
Alice:然后发现就没有喜欢的那种蓝色
Alice: Then I realized I couldn't find the blue I liked.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:我就我就换了
Alice: So I changed it.
Alice:你看这个是我自己的那个小海星
Alice: Look, this is my little starfish.
Alice:我就真的很喜欢海洋
Alice: I really love the ocean.
Lucia: 好好看哇好好看
Lucia: So pretty, wow, so pretty.
Lucia: 这是你自己自己设计的吗
Lucia: Did you design this yourself?
Lucia: 自己做的啊
Lucia: Made it yourself, huh?
Lucia: 好看耶
Lucia: Looks great!
Lucia: 我想想我们学校之前有一个课
Lucia: I remember our school had a class before.
Lucia: 就他有点像电工实习
Lucia: It was kind of like an electrician internship.
Lucia: 但不完全一样
Lucia: But not exactly the same.
Lucia: 就是也会自己做节制
Lucia: We also made stuff ourselves.
Lucia: 对然后我当时做的也是一个星星
Lucia: Yeah, I made a star back then too.
Lucia: 不过不是
Lucia: But it wasn't...
Jake:卢亚来帮帮个忙帮个忙
Jake: Lucia, come help, come help.
Jake:那个有有点离谱
Jake: This is a bit ridiculous.
Lucia: what's wrong
Lucia: What's wrong?
Jake:我一不小心按到了这个电源键
Jake: I accidentally pressed the power button.
Jake:我要松的话我就凉了
Jake: If I let go, it's over for me.
Jake:所以
Jake: So...
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Jake:所以你要帮我把所有硬盘都退出去
Jake: So you need to help me eject all the hard drives.
Lucia: 怎么退
Lucia: How do I eject them?
Jake:就是就是那个退出退出
Jake: Just, just eject them.
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Hold on.
Lucia: 天呐不是您真的情绪好稳定
Lucia: My gosh, you're really keeping your cool.
Jake:哈哈哈不是您听的心虚
Jake: Haha, you sound nervous.
Jake:好稳哈哈哈
Jake: So calm, haha.
Jake:就是地雷知道吧
Jake: You know about landmines, right?
Lucia: 我我我怎样怎样
Lucia: What do I, what do I do?
Jake:哎右下角有一个这个USB看到对
Jake: Hey, there's a USB icon at the bottom right, see it?
Jake:然后退出退出
Jake: Then eject, eject.
Lucia: 你这里有一个输入法
Lucia: You have an input method here.
Lucia: 我帮你挪一下可以吗
Lucia: Can I move it for you?
Jake:啊不用不用
Jake: Ah, no need, no need.
Jake:你就直接点左边的这个
Jake: Just click the one on the left.
Lucia: 最下下面的这个就是退出号
Lucia: The bottom one, that's eject, right?
Jake:最下面最下面这个对对对
Jake: The very bottom one, yes, yes.
Lucia: 他得退一会吗不
Lucia: Does it take a while to eject?
Jake:啊你摁一下
Jake: Ah, just press it.
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What happened?
Jake:嗯使劲摁
Jake: Uh, press harder.
Jake:或者你摁
Jake: Or press...
Jake:哎对
Jake: Ah, right.
Alice:桌上只有两瓶
Alice: There are only two bottles on the table.
Alice:应该就是我放的那一瓶
Alice: It should be the one I put there.
Lucia: 弹出失败
Lucia: Pop-up failed.
Jake:哦呃呃
Jake: Oh, uhh...
Lucia: 那就取消一下再试一次
Lucia: Then cancel it and try again.
Lucia: 你看哪个电脑比较方便
Lucia: See which computer is more convenient.
Lucia: 我先操作那个电脑
Lucia: I'll operate that computer first.
Lucia: 然后接下来的我就可以照本宣科了
Lucia: Then I can follow the instructions step-by-step.
Jake:好你看我
Jake: Okay, watch me.
Jake:啊就是就是这个
Jake: Ah, it's, it's this one.
Lucia: 啊原来不是统一的嗯
Lucia: Ah, so it's not unified, huh?
Jake:嘿嘿哎搞笑
Jake: Haha, funny.
Lucia: 一会等他们回来
Lucia: We'll wait until they come back.
Jake:吹随
Jake: Sure thing.
Lucia: 我要我要给他们讲这个故事
Lucia: I want to tell them this story.
Jake:这个故事确实挺好讲
Jake: This story is indeed worth telling.
Lucia: 不行您真的情绪太稳定了
Lucia: No, you are just too calm.
Alice:欣赏我们的花吧
Alice: Appreciate our flowers.
Jake:能补救还没死
Jake: It's salvageable, not dead yet.
Alice:但是你这个就是一只
Alice: But this one is just a single...
Alice:上面就好几个头
Alice: There are several heads on it.
Alice:就这种高度
Alice: This height...
Alice:这个高度是没办法变的
Alice: This height can't be changed.
Lucia: 他好像有点不是很灵光的样子
Lucia: It seems like he's a bit not very smart.
Alice:我好像单针的比较多
Alice: I seem to have more single needles.
Lucia: 你你在这里操作一下呢看
Lucia: You, you try operating here.
Lucia: 对他刚才就会提示这个
Lucia: Yeah, he just prompts this.
Lucia: 弹出失败什么什么的
Lucia: Pop-up failed something something.
Alice:外边纸箱吗
Alice: The outer cardboard box?
Alice:要不先留一下
Alice: Why not leave it for now?
Jake:可以有
Jake: That's possible.
Alice:哦谢谢阿姨
Alice: Oh, thanks, auntie.
Jake:有弹出嘛
Jake: Did it pop up?
Lucia: 呃
Lucia: Uhh...
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hello?
Lucia: 我感觉好像没有
Lucia: I feel like it didn't.
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hello?
Tasha: 拿快递是吗
Tasha: Picking up a package, right?
Jake:可能要到这点
Jake: Might have to wait until this time.
Lucia: 啊你这个还在备份
Lucia: Ah, you're still backing this up?
Tasha: 我想我问一下
Tasha: I think I have a question.
Jake:到实践了
Jake: Time to practice.
Lucia: 此电脑
Lucia: This computer.
Jake:哎呦我去实践了啊
Jake: Oh, I need to practice now.
Jake:到这个右键
Jake: Right-click here.
Jake:这也没有
Jake: It's not here either.
Tasha: 你好
Tasha: Hello.
Lucia: 好像没有属性底下就没别的了吧
Lucia: Seems like there's nothing else under properties, right?
Lucia: 呃确实属性下就没别了
Lucia: Uh, yeah, there's nothing else under properties.
Jake:我靠这沙雕360
Jake: Damn, this stupid 360 software.
Jake:我先把360关了
Jake: I'll just close 360 first.
Lucia: 那用他自带的那个优盘弹出试试看
Lucia: How about using the built-in eject option for the USB?
Jake:对就是他
Jake: Yeah, that's the one.
Tasha: 今天也不去拿快递是吗
Tasha: So, not picking up the package today?
Jake:什么快递
Jake: What package?
Tasha: 啊嗯没有人拿要不下次再拿吧
Tasha: Ah, um, no one's picking it up, maybe we'll get it next time.
Jake:你要去拿快递吗
Jake: Are you going to pick up the package?
Jake:呃你说今天有些快递到了
Jake: Uh, you said some packages arrived today?
Tasha: 我上午的时候好像就说有
Tasha: I think I mentioned it this morning.
Jake:会有然后你手机他怎么跟你讲
Jake: There should be, what did your phone say?
Tasha: 他跟我说他在
Tasha: It said it's here.
Jake:他他说哎
Jake: It said, hey.
Jake:现在可以
Jake: Now we can.
Lucia: 那要不把把那个
Lucia: How about we, um...
Jake:口琴对就行了
Jake: The harmonica, yeah, that's fine.
Lucia: 就是啊这样就弹出来那个
Lucia: Yeah, so this way, it will pop out.
Jake:你继续说
Jake: Go on.
Jake:我没再再再讲一下
Jake: I wasn't, say it again.
Tasha: 他说他今天现在在
Tasha: He said he's here today.
Jake:现在在好
Jake: He's here now, okay.
Tasha: 嗯但其实不是很重要的快递
Tasha: But it's not an important package.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:你你你跟房东讲你他让你怎么取啊
Jake: Did you tell the landlord how to pick it up?
Jake:你报手机尾号是吧
Jake: You need to give the last digits of your phone number, right?
Jake:应该是吧
Jake: Should be, right?
Tasha: 应该吧我不知道9707
Tasha: I think so, I don't know, 9707.
Jake:你手机尾号是什么
Jake: What's the last digits of your phone number?
Jake:京东
Jake: JD.com.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right
Jake:京东
Jake: JD.com
Tasha: 那他是房东拿来送来了吗
Tasha: Did the landlord bring it over?
Jake:还好有两只手
Jake: Good thing I have two hands
Lucia: 哈哈哈您怎么情绪这么稳定
Lucia: Hahaha, how are you so calm?
Jake:对京京东
Jake: Yeah, JD.com
Jake:呃是的是的
Jake: Uh, yes, yes
Jake:111707
Jake: 111707
Tasha: 9707
Jake:9707
Jake: 9707
Jake:好的哎呦
Jake: Okay, ouch
Lucia: 是不是也可以让他拿了快递
Lucia: Can we also have him pick up the package?
Tasha: 喂你好
Tasha: Hello, hi
Lucia: 然后送过来
Lucia: And bring it over?
Jake:我去是是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes, yes
Lucia: 就是这个民宿管家
Lucia: It's the B&B manager
Lucia: 啊那太好
Lucia: Ah, that's great
Jake:就是可以不兜
Jake: It means we don't have to go
Jake:风他们其实不想让我们兜风
Jake: They actually don't want us to go out
Lucia: 了这个没有360就直接弹出呗
Lucia: So it pops up without 360, right?
Jake:这个没有
Jake: This doesn't have it
Jake:对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes
Jake:这个就好
Jake: This is good
Jake:这就好点了
Jake: This is better
Jake:早上的那个毫米波也是因为360转了
Jake: This morning's millimeter wave was also because the 360 was turned
Katrina: 要训练一下
Katrina: Need to train a bit
Jake:很多马
Jake: A lot of horses
Lucia: 我点完之后哎
Lucia: After I clicked, hey
Lucia: 这是安全弹出的意思
Lucia: It means it's a safe pop-up
Lucia: 他这个小弹的是吧
Lucia: It pops up small, right?
Jake:已经弹了是吧
Jake: It popped up, right?
Jake:这边没有哎
Jake: It's not here
Lucia: 对没有了
Lucia: Yeah, it's gone
Jake:这边没有
Jake: It's not here
Lucia: 应该没有
Lucia: Shouldn't be
Jake:那就行这个是修硕的
Jake: That's fine, this is Shure's
Jake:修硕也把它给关掉
Jake: Shure will turn it off too
Jake:然后这个是
Jake: And this one is
Lucia: 这SELYX雨轩的吧
Lucia: This is SELYX Yuxuan's, right?
Jake:这是对宇轩的
Jake: This is for Yuxuan
Lucia: 可能是好
Lucia: Maybe it's good.
Jake:好弹出来了给他关掉
Jake: Alright, it popped up, close it.
Jake:对然后这是Lucia的
Jake: Yes, and this is Lucia's.
Lucia: 然后这个
Lucia: And this one.
Jake:坐坐
Jake: Have a seat.
Jake:你不用像我这么慌
Jake: You don't have to be as nervous as me.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我觉得我比你要慌一些
Lucia: Hahaha, I think I'm more nervous than you.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 您怎么情绪这么稳定
Lucia: How are you so calm?
Lucia: 这个好像也没有360
Lucia: This doesn't seem to have 360.
Lucia: 也是直接点这个呗
Lucia: Just click this directly, right?
Lucia: 现在
Lucia: Now.
Lucia: AI是不是收集到了一些很神奇的数据
Lucia: Has the AI collected some amazing data?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:现在知道怎么让人不关机
Jake: Now we know how to prevent shutdowns.
Jake:怎么让自己不关机
Jake: How to prevent ourselves from shutting down.
Lucia: 他现在他提示这个安全移除
Lucia: Now it's prompting for safe removal.
Lucia: 就是代表OK了OK
Lucia: That means it's OK, OK.
Jake:这就OK了
Jake: It's OK now.
Jake:OK了
Jake: OK.
Jake:然后这个就是卢西亚的我就关掉了
Jake: And this is Lucia's, I'll close it.
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Jake:挺好帮我操作了一番
Jake: Pretty good, you helped me a lot.
Jake:体验体验卡体验卡
Jake: Test card, test card.
Lucia: 这是多少
Lucia: How much is this?
Lucia: 六六 7个屏幕体验卡
Lucia: Six, six, 7-screen test card.
Lucia: 这好像也没有360
Lucia: This doesn't seem to have 360 either.
Jake:对对挺好
Jake: Right, right, pretty good.
Jake:对就这上面呢有个360
Jake: Yes, there is a 360 on this one.
Lucia: 那就直接直接弹出就行
Lucia: Then just pop it out directly.
Lucia: 这个这个窗口要关吗
Lucia: Do we need to close this window?
Jake:不用管不用管
Jake: No need, no need.
Lucia: 不用管它
Lucia: Don't need to bother with it.
Lucia: 我觉得电脑是一个
Lucia: I think computers are just...
Lucia: 经常莫名其妙就自己抽分的玩意
Lucia: Things that often act up for no reason.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Lucia: 就是也可能因为我不是学这个的啊
Lucia: Maybe because I didn't study this stuff, huh.
Jake:哈是他确实确实会丑确实会丑
Jake: Haha, yeah, they do act up, they do act up.
Lucia: 但总之我经常这么觉得
Lucia: But anyway, I often feel this way.
Lucia: 这应该应该也好了
Lucia: This should be fine.
Jake:嗯好好没问题
Jake: Yeah, sure, no problem.
Lucia: 这个我看不到那个那个啥了
Lucia: I can't see that thing anymore.
Lucia: 他应该已经弹出
Lucia: It should have popped up by now.
Lucia: 对这个是z z z x是水L3 这是
Lucia: Yes, this is z z z x is water L3. This is...
Jake:呃张夏是微微微
Jake: Uh, Zhang Xia is...very very...
Jake:要不给我拍个照吧
Jake: How about taking a picture for me?
Lucia: 这个这个好像就有
Lucia: This one seems to have it.
Lucia: 就有360啊
Lucia: It has 360.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 这你看不到是吗
Lucia: You can't see this, right?
Jake:不是给我拍个照
Jake: No, take a picture for me.
Lucia: 啊你你现在啊
Lucia: Oh, you mean now?
Jake:哈哈哈对好行
Jake: Hahaha, yeah, right now.
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 我拿你手机拍也行
Lucia: I can use your phone to take it.
Jake:哎对都都行都行
Jake: Yeah, that's fine, whatever works.
Lucia: 啊那行有什么想要的角度吗
Lucia: Do you have any specific angle you want?
Jake:有什么想要的角度吗
Jake: Any specific angle?
Jake:没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Lucia: 你哪个角度比较比较觉
Lucia: Any angle you think looks good.
Lucia: 自己觉得比较好看的可以
Lucia: The one you think looks best.
Jake:哈哈没有没有不用看镜头
Jake: Haha, no, no need to look at the camera.
Lucia: 那要不看镜头
Lucia: So don't look at the camera?
Lucia: 1二三OK
Lucia: One, two, three, okay.
Lucia: 一会发您
Lucia: I'll send it to you later.
Jake:都可以啊
Jake: That's fine.
Lucia: 还是发群里
Lucia: Or send it to the group?
Jake:群里可以
Jake: The group is fine.
Lucia: 刚到哪了
Lucia: Where were we?
Lucia: 这个这个是有360的
Lucia: This one has 360.
Jake:对那就关掉360
Jake: Yeah, then turn off 360.
Jake:对右下角有一个这个
Jake: Yeah, there's this thing in the bottom right corner.
Lucia: 三角那个吗这个
Lucia: The triangle one, right?
Jake:对然后右键关掉它
Jake: Yeah, then right-click to close it.
Jake:还好屋里有人
Jake: Good thing someone's here.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake:要不然我就在这盯着盯到各位回家
Jake: Otherwise, I'd be staring at this until everyone comes back.
Lucia: 等到大家回来
Lucia: Until everyone comes back.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 然后再再那个用Windows自带的那个
Lucia: And then, use the built-in Windows feature.
Lucia: 弹出
Lucia: Pop-up.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 应该没有了
Lucia: There shouldn't be any more.
Lucia: 他那个窗口就消失了
Lucia: That window should disappear.
Lucia: OK这个是s
Lucia: Okay, this is s...
Lucia: s k x
Lucia: s, k, x.
Lucia: 上来这个我们已经退过了吗
Lucia: Did we already return this one?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Lucia: 哦还没有哦
Lucia: Oh, not yet?
Jake:刚好是310
Jake: It's exactly 310.
Jake:没有成功把他盘他
Jake: We didn't manage to get him.
Lucia: 这外面是直升机吗
Lucia: Is that a helicopter outside?
Lucia: 这个声音
Lucia: That sound.
Lucia: 哦哦sorry
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Jake:我我我不知道
Jake: I, I, I don't know.
Jake:有可能是直升机
Jake: It could be a helicopter.
Lucia: 听着真的很像直升机
Lucia: It really sounds like a helicopter.
Lucia: 但这个地方有什么必要
Lucia: But what's the need for one here?
Jake:或者是飞机
Jake: Or maybe a plane.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:不知道确实不知道拖拉机
Jake: I really don't know, maybe a tractor.
Lucia: 这是l e
Lucia: This is l e.
Lucia: 这个东西不用管他吗
Lucia: Should we ignore this?
Lucia: 就您这还有一个正在备份的
Lucia: There's another one backing up.
Jake:这个宾馆我我已经火了
Jake: This hotel, I, I, I'm already on fire.
Lucia: 啊好
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 哈哈哈不用谢
Lucia: Hahaha, you're welcome.
Jake:谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Jake:谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 我们中午吃饭
Lucia: We had lunch.
Lucia: 你还没上来的时候
Lucia: While you weren't here.
Lucia: 大家其实在讨论你是不是一个AI
Lucia: Everyone was actually discussing if you're an AI.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈因为情绪过于稳定
Lucia: Hahaha, because your emotions are too stable.
Jake:不好是吧
Jake: Not good, huh?
Jake:麻了
Jake: Numb.
Lucia: 大家easy不会争吵看看又什么灵感
Lucia: Everyone, easy, no arguing. Let's see if there's any inspiration.
Lucia: 我决定抄一下
Lucia: I decided to jot this down.
Lucia: 不过改一个颜色
Lucia: But just change the color
Lucia: 没有开玩笑开玩笑
Lucia: Just kidding, kidding
Alice:这个还行
Alice: This one is okay
Alice:但不是我想要的那种颜色
Alice: But it's not the color I want
Alice:但可以先加进去
Alice: But we can add it first
Alice:然后慢慢删
Alice: And then gradually remove it
Lucia: 我觉得我现在那几个装饰
Lucia: I think my decorations now
Lucia: 都还是墙面的装饰
Lucia: Are all wall decorations
Lucia: 没有什么桌子上的
Lucia: There's nothing for the table
Lucia: 因为我那个房间里面没有
Lucia: Because in my room, there is no
Lucia: 没有桌子
Lucia: No table
Lucia: 他只有一个小架子
Lucia: There's only a small shelf
Lucia: 你那里面有桌子吗
Lucia: Do you have a table in yours?
Alice:你可以去看
Alice: You can go look
Lucia: 呃可能会扫到
Lucia: Uh, I might sweep it
Alice:无所谓我收拾过了哈哈哈
Alice: It doesn't matter, I've tidied up, hahaha
Lucia: 啊那我看过了
Lucia: Ah, then I've looked
Lucia: 啊那我看一眼
Lucia: Ah, let me take a look
Shure: 他不一定
Shure: Not necessarily
Alice:你看我我那有个桌子上上面有个灯
Alice: Look, I have a table with a lamp on it
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Lucia: 哦哎
Lucia: Oh, hey
Lucia: 那你这个很好看
Lucia: This looks nice
Lucia: 我那里面只有一个架子
Lucia: I only have a shelf in mine
Lucia: 就是像这种置物布局是一样的
Lucia: The arrangement is similar to this
Alice:今天不是一样的吗
Alice: Isn't it the same today?
Lucia: 但是就是它家具没有桌子
Lucia: But it doesn't have a table
Lucia: 它只有一个置物架
Lucia: It only has a shelf
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So
Lucia: 我就想给那个置物架上再放一个
Lucia: I was thinking of putting another
Lucia: 那种小小的收纳
Lucia: Small storage box on the shelf
Lucia: 收纳箱那种
Lucia: To make it tidier
Lucia: 让它整齐一些
Lucia: 啊这个小灯挺好看的
Lucia: Ah, this small lamp looks nice
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia: 我说那个小灯挺好看的
Lucia: I said that small lamp looks nice
Alice:你没有灯吗
Alice: You don't have a lamp?
Lucia: 我没有
Lucia: I don't
Alice:你只有上面的灯吗对
Alice: You only have the ceiling light, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right
Lucia: 是不是很amazing哈
Lucia: Isn't it amazing?
Alice:我以为我们是等比例复制粘贴
Alice: I thought we were copying and pasting proportionally.
Lucia: 哈我们的房型是一样
Lucia: Haha, our room layout is the same.
Lucia: 但是里面的东西不太一样
Lucia: But the things inside are a bit different.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 搞一个蓝色的什么布
Lucia: Get a piece of blue cloth or something.
Lucia: 把床铺一铺好
Lucia: Make the bed properly.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:都回来了吗
Jake: Is everyone back?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:雨轩也没回来哈
Jake: Yuxuan isn't back either, huh.
Jake:他那个也先弄
Jake: Let's get his done first.
Jake:可以小组长就是比素媛
Jake: Our group leader is better than Suyuan.
Jake:哈哈哈上心哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, so dedicated, hahaha.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 有没有一点人服感
Shure: Do you feel a bit of human touch?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 人服感
Shure: Human touch.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Like,
Shure: 人肤感就是
Shure: human skin touch.
Jake:哈哈哈人肤懂了懂了
Jake: Hahaha, I get it, human skin touch.
Shure: 人人机感和人肤感对
Shure: Human-machine touch and human skin touch, right.
Jake:有有有
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:学到一些很难翻译的东西
Jake: Learning some really hard-to-translate stuff.
Shure: 这怎么
Shure: How do you...
Jake:这么翻
Jake: How do you translate this?
Shure: host husband
Shure: Host husband.
Shure: style感feeling yeah
Shure: Style feeling, yeah.
Shure: feeling of host husband
Shure: Feeling of host husband.
Shure: 我去楼上吃饭一会
Shure: I'm going upstairs to have a meal for a bit.
Jake:对去布置布置
Jake: Yeah, go set things up.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:我们拖桌子去吧
Jake: Let's move the table.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Alice:为啥一看淘宝就困
Alice: Why do I feel sleepy as soon as I look at Taobao?
Lucia: 物业
Lucia: Property management.
Lucia: 要不然上面凳子就不够了
Lucia: Otherwise, there won't be enough chairs up there.
Jake:现在几点
Jake: What time is it now?
Shure: 现在快6点了吧
Shure: It's almost 6 o'clock now, I think.
Shure: 应该 5:46差不多了
Shure: It should be around 5:46.
Jake:差不多
Jake: Almost done.
Jake:拆吧这怎么还开着
Jake: Take it apart, why is this still on?
Jake:这亮灯啥
Jake: Why is this light on?
Shure: 一些红外信号吧
Shure: It's probably some infrared signal.
Lucia: 我又把这凳子给搬上来了
Lucia: I brought the chair back up again.
Jake:哎呦好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry about that.
Shure: 适度可以
Shure: Just right, it's okay.
Lucia: 要不然攒一会不够123456
Lucia: Otherwise, we won't have enough chairs for a while, right?
Lucia: 要不来俩人坐这上面
Lucia: Maybe two people can sit on it?
Katrina: 对一般都是B0
Katrina: Yeah, usually it's B0.
Lucia: 这是谁的
Lucia: Whose is this?
Jake:哎呀这东西咋整
Jake: Oh no, what should we do with this?
Lucia: 这灯要不就把它放这这样转过来
Lucia: Should we turn this lamp around and place it here?
Lucia: 因为咱接下来两天还要练舞的话
Lucia: Because we're going to practice dancing for the next two days.
Lucia: 那他就可以一直在这打着对吧
Lucia: So it can keep shining here, right?
Lucia: 这个搬一点吃饭用
Lucia: Move this a bit for dining purposes.
Shure: 要不插到花盆里
Shure: How about we stick it in a flowerpot?
Jake:花盆不够高
Jake: The flowerpot isn't tall enough.
Jake:正好有一个什么东西
Jake: We need something else, anything else.
Jake:就是这都不行
Jake: This won't work at all.
Jake:这样的都不行
Jake: This way won't work either.
Shure: 这样
Shure: Like this.
Shure: 然后放
Shure: Then place it...
Shure: 放到放到放到这个这这上面就正好
Shure: Place it on top of this, just right.
Shure: 应该是吧
Shure: Should be, right?
Shure: 哎呦不行
Shure: Oh no, it won't work.
Jake:再多一点或者硬一点的东西
Jake: We need something more, or something harder.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 把它翻过来然后
Lucia: Flip it over, then...
Lucia: 翻过来扣在这上面
Lucia: Flip it over and place it on top.
Jake:翻过来放在下面
Jake: Flip it and put it underneath.
Lucia: 哦然后在上面再垫个纸
Lucia: Oh, then put some paper on top.
Lucia: 那估计还行
Lucia: That might work.
Lucia: 这里面有没有垃圾
Lucia: Is there any trash in here?
Lucia: 哇这个这这个
Lucia: Wow, this, this...
Lucia: 这个空调怎么关啊
Lucia: How do you turn off this air conditioner?
Lucia: 这上面吹的好冷
Lucia: It's blowing so cold up here.
Shure: 喊他关他就关了
Shure: Just tell it to turn off, it'll turn off.
Lucia: 真的吗语音控制的
Lucia: Really? It's voice-controlled?
Shure: 这不是这是电视遥控器
Shure: No, this is the TV remote.
Jake:在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Shure: 我们一会可能会热
Shure: We might get hot later.
Shure: 所以一会再开对
Shure: So, we'll turn it on later, right?
Jake:一会再开吧
Jake: Let's turn it on later.
Lucia: 对一会要上来煮火锅的话再开
Lucia: Yes, when we start cooking the hotpot, we can turn it on.
Jake:是吗啊
Jake: Is that so?
Shure: 竖竖向是吗
Shure: Vertical, right?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Got it.
Lucia: 要帮忙吗
Lucia: Need help?
Shure: 一二哎
Shure: One, two, hey...
Jake:暂暂且不要
Jake: Not for now.
Jake:可能就要了
Jake: Maybe soon.
Lucia: 感觉你们俩小心
Lucia: Be careful, you two.
Jake:果然还是要帮忙
Jake: Looks like we do need help.
Lucia: 碰到这个
Lucia: Watch out for this.
Jake:继续吧
Jake: Let's continue.
Shure: 你的屁股蹭到了是吗
Shure: Did your butt brush against it?
Jake:这个地方夹到
Jake: It got stuck here.
Shure: 啊我以为是臀部太翘了
Shure: Ah, I thought your butt was just too big.
Shure: 好差不多差不多
Shure: Okay, that's about right.
Shure: 然后煮火锅时候大家把门关好
Shure: When we cook the hotpot, make sure to close the doors.
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Got it.
Shure: 不然话熏的屋里都是那个味
Shure: Otherwise, the smell will fill the whole room.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 那个就先暂且这样吧
Lucia: Let's just leave it like this for now.
Jake:来摆桌子
Jake: Come, set up the table.
Jake:正好吧
Jake: Looks good.
Lucia: 椅子有6个
Lucia: We have six chairs.
Shure: 啊上午的时候桌子没擦
Shure: Ah, we didn't wipe the table this morning.
Lucia: 然后再
Lucia: Then we...
Shure: 擦一下
Shure: Let's wipe it.
Lucia: 这个这个腿每次都会掉下来吗
Lucia: Does this leg fall off every time?
Shure: 他是吊脚脚
Shure: It's a dangling leg.
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Lucia: 往哪边推比较
Lucia: Which way to push it?
Lucia: 把这俩凳子都放到这边
Lucia: Put these two chairs over here.
Lucia: 然后把那个推到那边
Lucia: Then push that over there.
Lucia: 能推
Lucia: Can we push it?
Lucia: 能推下
Lucia: Can it be pushed?
Jake:嗯可以再来点
Jake: Yeah, we can add some more.
Jake:很有意思
Jake: Very interesting.
Jake:很很有意思
Jake: Very, very interesting.
Lucia: 对楼下还有
Lucia: Yes, there's more downstairs.
Jake:到时候再搬上来
Jake: We'll move it up later.
Jake:两个有好处
Jake: Having two is beneficial.
Jake:挺好挺好
Jake: Great, great.
Jake:来都来了
Jake: Since we're here...
Alice:go吗 123
Alice: Ready? 1, 2, 3.
Jake:还差1个
Jake: We're still missing one.
Shure: 这锁是坏的
Shure: This lock is broken.
Lucia: 所以大家在这里上洗手间的时候
Lucia: So when everyone uses the bathroom here,
Lucia: 要养成先敲门的习惯
Lucia: you should get into the habit of knocking first.
Shure: 真的没人
Shure: Seriously, no one's in there.
Shure: 啊太饿了
Shure: Ah, I'm so hungry.
Jake:hello
Jake: Hello.
Shure: nice to meet you
Shure: Nice to meet you.
Shure: 往上拿东西吧哎
Shure: Let's carry these things up.
Lucia: 这个都拿上去
Lucia: Take all of this upstairs.
Lucia: 先这样吧
Lucia: Let's do it this way for now.
Shure: 所以可能有点脏
Shure: So, it might be a bit dirty.
Shure: 得稍微擦一下
Shure: We need to wipe it a bit.
Lucia: 我已经拿出来了
Lucia: I've already taken it out.
Tasha: 还有东西要拿吗
Tasha: Is there anything else to take?
Tasha: 我就问肉
Tasha: I'm just asking about the meat.
Lucia: 啊就是火锅用的东西
Lucia: Oh, it's just stuff for the hotpot.
Tasha: 对对
Tasha: Right, right.
Lucia: 基本上可以都拿上去
Lucia: Basically, everything can go up.
Tasha: 还有蒜蒜
Tasha: There’s also some garlic.
Shure: 蒜
Shure: Garlic.
Shure: 蒜需要拿吗
Shure: Do we need to take the garlic?
Shure: 应该不用吧
Shure: Probably not.
Tasha: 要不要把锅拿上去
Tasha: Should we bring the pot up?
Shure: 哪个锅
Shure: Which pot?
Tasha: 就在这个底下
Tasha: The one under here.
Shure: 哦这有鸳鸯锅
Shure: Oh, there's a yin-yang pot.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Wow.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yes.
Shure: 牛逼啊
Shure: Awesome.
Shure: 然后电磁
Shure: And it's electric.
Tasha: 哎有两个鸳鸯锅
Tasha: Oh, there are two yin-yang pots.
Tasha: 正好要两个呢
Tasha: 因为不是桌子很大吗
Tasha: Because the table is pretty big, right?
Shure: 主要底料没有那么多
Shure: Mainly, we don't have much base.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 牛油底料很多
Shure: We've got plenty of beef broth base.
Shure: 但是清汤的和菌汤的只有一个
Shure: But there's only one clear soup and one mushroom soup.
Tasha: 清汤的一个菌汤
Tasha: One clear soup, one mushroom soup.
Shure: 啊不是
Shure: Ah, no.
Shure: 就是菌只有菌汤的
Shure: There's only mushroom soup.
Tasha: 只有菌汤
Tasha: Only mushroom soup.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 要不就一个纯蜡的
Shure: How about one pure wax,
Shure: 然后一个那什么的
Shure: and one of the other kind.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Sure.
Shure: 但是有那么多电磁炉吗
Shure: But do we have that many induction cookers?
Tasha: 要不要洗一下电磁炉
Tasha: Should we clean an induction cooker?
Tasha: 哪有电磁炉
Tasha: Where's the induction cooker?
Tasha: 这有有两个
Tasha: There are two here.
Tasha: 还楼上还有个卡式炉呢所以够
Tasha: And there's a cassette stove upstairs, so it's enough.
Shure: 行那你拿一个电磁炉吧
Shure: Alright, you grab an induction cooker.
Shure: 你拿着这个我拿
Shure: You take this, I'll take...
Tasha: 呃我我还要拿食材
Tasha: Uh, I still need to get the ingredients.
Shure: 那先先上去一趟
Shure: Then let's go upstairs first.
Tasha: 楼上有一个卡式炉
Tasha: There's a cassette stove upstairs.
Tasha: 再拿一个电磁炉就行
Tasha: Just grab another induction cooker.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 你在干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Jake:监工
Jake: Supervising.
Jake:给他加油打气
Jake: Cheering him on.
Shure: 监工导书记是吗
Shure: Supervising, huh?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 插排拿过来
Shure: Bring the power strip over.
Shure: 插排不够长吧
Shure: The power strip isn't long enough, is it?
Shure: 够吗
Shure: Is it enough?
Shure: 插排不够长
Shure: The power strip isn't long enough.
Shure: 再接个插排
Shure: Connect another strip.
Jake:打牌不够长
Jake: The strip isn't long enough.
Jake:再接呗再接一个
Jake: Connect another one.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.